first a sophisticated late breakfast or
brunch dish to impress your mates easy
griddle polenta with delicious roasty
tomatoes and creamy goats curd
now polenta to the italians is what
mashed potatoes to britain's a staple
incredibly delicious and really
straightforward to do now season the
water
just a little touch of olive oil stops
it from becoming too sticky
i love polenta it's a cornmeal made from
ground dried maize
the more coarse the longer it takes to
cook but you can also buy instant
polenta which is ready in under 10
minutes and always use this at home
and then
whisk that out
as it cooks out it naturally thickens
you see the grains becoming almost into
one nice fine pureed
polenta
to take the polenta to another level
flavor-wise season with salt and pepper
a good knob of butter and parmesan
quite generous with the parmesan because
polenta can be quite dull i like it
quite rich and creamy
delicious
now
mix that in
smell
a nice smooth
shiny glossy planter you can eat polenta
two ways like this it's a glorious
fluffy mash or set then griddled which
is what i'm doing
start by oiling a baking tray pour in
your polenta
now get that in the fridge and let it
set
next i'm roasting fine tomatoes to
really intensify their flavour
olive on the bottom of the tray
and drizzle extra virgin olive oil on
top
nip your tomatoes with your scissors if
you didn't burst them before they went
in the oven they'd explode salt
and pepper garlic
just squeeze the juice out the garlic so
as the tomatoes blister and roast it's
going gonna take on all this lovely
garlic
to give the tomatoes a wonderful sweet
and sour flavor a pinch of sugar and
balsamic vinegar
this is a wonderful aged balsamic
vinegar and then
some thyme
don't pick the time
just try it like you're having a little
haircut
nice
the tomatoes only take 10 minutes to
roast
now the plant is set it's ready to
griddle it should just fall out
beautiful polenta is a nice garnish for
grilled meats it's great when you're
planning a big dinner party the polenta
can be done one or two days before a
nice season
top and bottom
a nice sort of coating of olive oil and
then onto your grill
now
this looks very impressive but it's so
easy to do
get that grill really nice and hot make
sure you've got a fish slice and go
underneath
to turn
all that nice sort of marking
and char in the blender gives that
really nice flavor
now
tomatoes look
you got these beautiful vine tomatoes
have been roasted and all that wonderful
flavor
[Music]
now
get your little tomatoes and just sit
them on top
drizzle over any remaining roasting
juices
the perfect addition is a goat's curd
goat's curd gives it that nice sort of
salty
creamy
taste goat's cheese cream cheese or
creme fraiche will work just as well
drizzle
a little touch
of that aged barcelona vinegar and then
a little basil
i can't wait to dive in
this dish is fantastic when you're
entertaining in the morning set your
plenty the night before and you can have
this casual brunch on the table within
minutes fuss-free cooking that looks
like a labor of love
roasted tomato soup
beautiful vine tomatoes the ripe of the
tomatoes the better the soup
take the core out get your thumb and
place it half a centimetre underneath
the tip of your knife place it in and
then just twist round that's the only
part of the tomato that we're not using
red onion
and garlic
red onion because it's sweeter than a
white onion
slice your onions
and your garlic
it's nice and fine
traditionally you'd be making it in a
pot it's so much better to start it off
on top of the stove the searing the
tomatoes and the garlic when it goes in
the oven
you actually roast the tomatoes and they
don't stew there's a big difference in
flavor be quite generous with the olive
oil it makes the soup nice and glossy
shiny
salt pepper and then a little teaspoon
of cayenne just gives it that heat but
it's not as fierce as chilli
take your tomatoes and just slice them
in half
and then
a little touch of sugar
that's going to help intensify the
sweetness
a little sprinkle
of aged bottled vinegar it gives that
nice dark rich acidity
to the soup
into the oven
20 25 minutes 180.
to make my soup even more irresistible
i'm going to make a punchy sun-dried
tomato pesto to drizzle over the top
now i'm making this in a pestle and
mortar because you feel
so much more in control
and you're not depending on a blade
that's whizzing around at a thousand
miles an hour
next in a dry pan toast off some pine
nuts
toast them the absolute max and then in
the smell in there is incredible
parmesan
lightly grate that
this is where it starts to become creamy
next virgin olive oil
doesn't need salt because the is going
to season it for you
and just take a couple tablespoons of
the oil that the sun-dried tomatoes are
in really helps to make that stunning
pesto
i can smell those roasted tomatoes want
them out
wow
next pour in a little vegetable stock or
chicken stock so it sits halfway up the
tomatoes
put your spoon through those tomatoes
they break up instantly
bring that up to the boil let it simmer
for three or four minutes
i want to make it a little bit more
creamy now
cream in
give that a little stir you can keep it
rustic and you get your masher in
and you've got that nice thick
rich
chunky tomato soup
or get yourself a stick blender
blitzing it like that you delays the
bottom of the pan and you get all those
amazing flavors from the bottom
that's delicious to make my lunch extra
hearty i'm gonna knock up a deliciously
gutsy version of cheese on toast to go
with my tomato soup
boss rabbit
an absolute classic i'm gonna make a
roux 50 grams of butter three nice
tablespoons of flour and that's all
there is basically traditionally you
would use flour butter
and milk
but in welsh rabbit the milk is often
cheekily substituted for a stiff slug of
stout
gives it that strong
gutsy flavor
i want it nice and thick make sure those
lumps are out
a nice teaspoon of dijon mustard and
then season it
nice and spicy moisture sauce gives it
that delicious
intriguing flavor now that smells
amazing
almost brings tears to your eyes
beautiful
now boss rabbit wouldn't be a stunning
welsh rabbit without rich mature cheese
soap and a great
montgomery cheddar
goes well with a beer
and drop that in
really important to put this in while
the roux is still nice and hot because
the cheese melts
now
for the bread
i prefer a good rustic country loaf that
will stand up to my hardcore topping
i want that nice crisp
base to my welsh rabbit so toast it both
sides
[Music]
spread that beautiful cheesy berry spicy
mixture
just
great
got a blister
and bubble and gratinate
god
a little splash alien perry
and back under the grill for 90 seconds
in one delicious
creamy roasted tomato soup it's coming
back to me all those days i had off
school i used to purposely lie about
feeling ill just to get a bowl of my
mother's tomato soup
how bad was that
but my god it was worth it
oh
now
oh i'll show you
[Music]
look at those babies that just takes
cheese on toast to another level
wow
roasted creamy tomato soup with a
sun-dried tomato pesto
served with the most amazing delicious
welsh rabbit
i feel like bringing in sick
[Music]
a delicious saffron flatbread with
mussels it doesn't get any healthier
than that first job the super easy
saffron flatbread
[Music]
put the saffron
into the bowl
and a couple of teaspoons of hot water
that starts to infuse
the saffron
and so you can maximize on the colour
across your flatbeds
to make the dough simply add plain flour
a pinch of salt and pepper to a bowl and
then pour in a dash of olive oil
that makes the dough nice and silky and
rich your saffron water you'll see how
concentrated it is now
and you'll need cold
water then simply need to bring the
dough together mop up
all your flour
you can see now
the saffron's activated it's got that
really nice color
beautiful
use your wrist
and just knead it nicely we'll do now is
smoothing out
the gluten strands
push
and tuck in
push and tuck in and each every time you
do this getting softer you just sort of
form
like this perfect
beautiful
dough
it smells delicious that saffron is very
powerful
now
sit that in your bowl cover it with clim
film let it rest for 10 to 15 minutes
this relaxes the dough making it easier
to roll and gives it time to infuse with
the saffron i'm gonna cut that into
three and then roll them nice and thinly
now
lightly flour the surface
and then
just
bring that
it's like a perfect ball
on the board
once you've got that nice ball your
rolling pin
and just roll it out
now
it doesn't get any simpler than that
and just lightly
flour that on top
a little salt
cooking the flatbread is easy just pop
in a hot dry pan and they're ready in
minutes as it hits the pan it starts the
blister
she's ready
for turning
beautiful get that color on there
now you want it nice and crisp almost
blistering on both sides because it's
nice and thin
it's cooked once browned on both sides
just cool on a rack flatbread's done now
on to the muscles now the secret
behind cooking
great muscles
is in the speed you cook
the key is to chop and prep your
ingredients before you start cooking
first thing pancetta i want it quite
chunky if you can't get pancetta i
always like to use a sort of streaky
bacon
because i want to sort of render all
that flavor
at the streaky bacon
now tomatoes garlic and chili cherry
tomatoes they're just going in whole
the garlic
just crush the garlic
so all that flavor comes out chilli
i want some heat in here
that's everything prepped now to get it
cooked little touch
of olive oil
pancetta in
pancetta takes moments once it's brown
and crisp put your garlic chili and
whole cherry tomatoes into the pan
mussels go in
okay and i'm using dry sherry i think it
works better in this recipe than white
wine which is classically used at this
stage
then oregano finely chopped stalks and
all i'll go on
and then just give that
a little mix
and we'll see those muscles
start to open lid goes on
you've got to lock in that flavor
gotta lock in
that heat the mussels will take four to
five minutes to steam in the meantime
cut your flatbreads into strips
crispy
and crunchy
now the mussels
wow that is incredible
my goodness me
[Music]
now that is one lunch i definitely don't
want to miss
healthy and delicious
doesn't get any better than that
incredible
steamed mussels with saffron flatbreads
made in minutes and packed with protein
and vitamins this is one fast food meal
that really is healthy
you